Hello-ah-huuuUUuugh... (Markisqueak)
Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Subnautica.
Now I-I forgot that I spawned outside of my PRAWN suit
and I just so happen to be in a dark, deep, depth of
~~HELL~~ over here and everything is horrible
and I hate everything and every-aughh God...
*nervous inhale* SO
what I wanna do, is, uh,
I need to get back to the surface,
I want to get to safety, an-uhh, first and foremost -
that's more important than anything that I'm doing right now -
but, uhh, I have limited amount
of food and water, and actually have no idea where
I am because because things seem so dark and dreary
that I feel like I'm going to lost in the
ether and NEVER BE ABLE TO FIND MY HOME AGAIN.
And that's entirely possible, but I need to get on the way back up
and I need to do that in a hurry because I'm running
out of food and water as I said before, and
that means that death is imminent, and
I have no hope, and everything is horrible
in front of me, so I'm gonna climb my way
back out of here, and hopefully-- (spooky music picks up...)
(...with words...?)
Did I hear a VOICE!?
Did-- (brief music vocals... hopefully.)
Did someone just SAY WORDS to me,
or am I going out of my goddammed mind??
Cuz I'm pretty sure I'm going out of my goddammed mind O_O;;
I'm fairly certain that that's exactly
what's going on here--
heyyyyou are horrifying...
EUUGHHHH.
You wanna get ground!?
You seem beautiful and peaceful, but
I know that guy is a dick over there, so
maybe he's just your bad neighbour, but...
oh my God, look at you!
Holy shit, what is WITH you?
I mean, I'm not one to criticize,
you're beautiful in your own way but oh my God...
Something is goin' horribly wrong with your body.
I dunno how you survive down here,
(sliiight Southern drawl) being the way you is
gorgeous, admittedly, but...
you know, just terrifying.
Is that titanium?
IS THAT TITANIUM?!
IS THAT FUCKIN' TITANIUM
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
Is that fuckin' titanium?
Oh my God, that's fuckin' titanium!
Holy shit, that's titanium!
So there are titanium deposits
out here that I can grind away!
And it does two for one!
Okay, but that's besides the point, because I'm about to
run out of everything... (distant Sancho agrees)
Good thing I've got big filtered water!
I'm a big boy,
with big filter water,
and big dreams!
So I'm gonna-beaurghglegle...
I'm gonna make my way back
but I'm gonna go over this way because there's some
bizarre structures over this way.
There -- that big tree?
I can't make my way down there just yet
it is too deep down
and I'm not gonna be able to get there,
so what I gotta do...
is ~I~
gotta make my way
I gotta swing-swong back up
th-oh shit
come on
PULL ME
PULL ME BABY
I gotta make my way back up this
way, what is that?
Have I seen that before?
Nickel ore?
Nickleback!?
Nickel ore, I've never even seen nickel ore before!
Okay, so there's sulphur down here and there's
nickel ore, both two new things
that I have not seen before, but I'm gonna try to gather
I didn't even notice that one
zip-zap-zappin' Spider-man
my way up
ZOOOOMMMM
ZOOOOMMMMM
ZOOOOMMMMMM
ZOOOOMMMMMMM
BEP
MMM, AARGH
'Bout to just spear myself to death on those things!
HOP-okay, thank you.
Man, I wouldn't be able to--
EERGH!
EWGH, you are a giant ver-
woah, okay, bye then, alright see ya...
Wow, that's version of the crab things
that are on the islands.
woah
WOAH
WOAH, this is a new area that I have not seen before!
HOOOLY SHIT!
WHAT THE FUCK
I don't have time time to see this shit!
Oh my God, I'm gonna eat one of you guys
if you come near me, but-uh--
i'm a little bit desperate, but this is
holy fuck
that is so WEIRD
what is this place?
This was right next to this, I mean, this is
this has got to be related some sou-
some sort of stuff that's
and what is this? is this more nickel?
Cuz' it looks different than anything that I've seen before,
but it might be something that I've seen,
I'm not sure --
yup, that's a big deposit of nickel here.
I dunno what good that's gonna do me, but I can't
stay risk out of my suit, that was
not English, and that was not good, but I
can't risk staying out of my suit
too long or else i'm gonna get killed by the crab
squids, I've literally only got one...
uh, one hit left in me, if I get hit once
I'm dead.
And that even means if I accidentally drift
into the--into the brine...
which is entirely possible, but I don't--
I don't want to risk it!
Okay, that's all the nickel that I'm going to get from that,
~hoooly fuckerino!
JESUS, look at this shit!
What the hell, it's HUGE!
This is fucking ginormous, I've never been down here,
I didn't even know this existed!
It's a whole 'nother section of the Lost
River, there is still brine that's running
through here, or sulphur, I think what it
actually is, it's not brine,
brine is just salt water, but
oh my God there's so many of those crab things,
and they're all staring at me
eugh
Oh, more titanium, but I don't need to worry about
that right now-- (echoing creature squeak)
(GASP)
fucking shut up with you~!
Okay then
I guess--
I guess the only way to go is up, but I've never even
known this was here!
How could I have known?
Ahh I don't have time to marvel at, um,
I'm gonna run out of food at any moment,
and I'm hoping this is gonna to loop back or at least loop out
of this place
maybe I can find another exit out of here,
and then I'll
eugh-oh fuck
it's just you.
And then I'll be able to
go my own way.
But it is
DISTURBINGLY QUIET down here,
that's another thing that I'm gonna admit about this,
it is (creature sound)
unabashedly
quiet, except for a few creatures
hither and tither
yegh
fuck...
OH hi friend
you know what?
God dammit
right as I find some sulphur, isn't it.
Ain't that just the shit, right as you
come across some sulphur,
the fucking warper
appe-okay bye then
nevermind, he heard me talking shit about him
and he decided to bugger on out of here!
Good!
He didn't want me to lay the smackdown on him --
if I get warped once, I'm probably gonna die.
(ambient creature noise)
Yeeesh
woahh!
Sorry, sorry, sorry, didn't mean to do that --
o-kay, well apparently I found the land of milk and honey
when it comes to... what I can only assume to be
either gold or copper
and then nickel
but right now-woah.
OHHH
the blood trees!
Or whatever they were,
I'm not--I'm not entirely sure what they are exactly
but those weird, like,
bulbous blood things...
The weird trees down in the
dark depths--
(more creature sounds)
agai-again I-it's either a whale
or a man screaming in pain!
Maybe a man wailing in pain if
I can be so bold, but
eugh...
oh, what is that
ah, jeez
gleughhh
glegh
okay, well this is horrifying
but I think might have been one of the ways
I also came into the Lost River before
they actually built this out...
Well that crabsquid is not looking good.
Also, he's clipping halfway through the bottom.
That crabsquid wasn't glowing spots of green
before, so I'm assuming that the disease
is coming at him...
...hot and heavy.
Don't even try me buddy.
(SNARLING CREATURE SOUND)
Woah, what the fuck?
Woooaaahh
yeeeee...!
Hey come on now!
You weren't so violent before!
You were like my friend!
oh, jeez
euaghhh
I imagine that touching the electrocuting
things ain't gonna be too good for me?
'Kay, so I gotta get out of here, because I only got 22% health left...
Fuck, I'm on the complete wrooang side...
Alright, come on, time to Spoder-man out
of here, we gotta GO!
We gotta go and find out what to do with this
sulphur and nickel first
and then we are gonna write down some names on the
on the lockers, and then we are gonna get out of here, but
we gotta get out of here first
alive preferably
ey-yayayay
NOPE, no you don't, no you don't, no you don't
nonononononono
no no, I don't have time for this bullshittery!
I have-I usually have a lot of time allotted
in my schedule for just general bullshittery,
but I don't have time right now.
Oh my god...
where am I?
Eugh, that's sinking into the darkness
okay...
a'right then...
not sure exactly where I am or where
I ended up, but I am a ways
away from where I needed to be, but
that is just bizarre!
Just this section right here, that's just
here
why?
and how?
ah shit, ah shit, ah shit,
I'm falling, I'm falling, I'm falling, I'm falling
please land on good land...!
(another monster sound maybe)
That didn't sound good...
Okay!
I think we are okay actually, I think we are in a good spot
I don't know where we are, cuz it's
pitch fucking black, but I think we're okay!
(groaning Sancho) ...maaybee...
So I'm right here, I was so stressed for no reason...
I'm literally right here!
How in the fuck did I get--
what are you--are you dead?
Must be? Question mark?
O-kay...
alright then, I'll eat you, thank you for your contribution...
So, there's an entrance to the Lost River
literally adjacent to
where the life pod is in the Safe Shallows,
that is... absurd.
I honestly had no idea about that
that is crazy...
Okay, but I gotta eat this thing right now
RIIGHT NOOW
and I got a bonefish too, I guess I could eat that
but...
Ha-bousky...
(Karen: Vital signs stabilizing.)
aaand...
haaaaa-BOUSKY!
Okay
so now that I got back to my thing,
I have new materials with which to use
but I need to go all the way back to my base
down below
I mean
I wish my seamoth could do what I needed it to do
but, I think the next step that I need to do is build
a cyclops, I need a mobile base
that can go way down deep into the
depths of the ocean,
while also being able to carry with me my PRAWN suit
and uh-I'll get to the lockers in
just a second as soon as I get back to my base, but
I'm gonna do some resource gathering before I
do that, so see ya in a bit!
Is that a diamond?
Is that really just...
Mercury ore??
Wait, have I ever gotten mercury ore?
Wait a minute, "cinnabar
heat in O2 to acquire refined mercury."
I don't know if I've ever gotten mercury ore before.
I didn't even know there was mercury ore
here...
have I gotten that?
Have I never gotten mercury ore?
How is that possible?
I have no goddamn idea
I-I guess I've never just walked down on the bottom here!
I don't even know if I need mercury ore, but
I seem to be gathering a lot of really rare materials
umm I don't know if they are really rare, I'm gonna assume they are rare
because I FOUND THEM, AND
THEREFORE THAT MEANS THEY ARE RARE!
...to me!
but anyways, I found them, so Imma gather 'em up
as best I can, and then
take them somewhere.
Lithium, yes please--
I didn't even god damn know!
How did I not god damn know?!
How could I be so dumb?!
E-SA-UGHHHLY!! (wut?)
♪♫ Hudle-de-dedle-dee-didlee  deet ♫♪
Comin' in hot n' heavy Kareeen-aauuuughhhhh
BOUSHKY.
okay
Don't know why there was so much dirt on the
top of my moonpool, but
I ain't gonna question it
alright Bumblebutt! you come with me~!
Let me just see if--
OH FUCK HI
WHAT THE FUCK.
OH OKAY
I'm gonna get in my base before you
have time to FUCK ME OVER!
Jesus Christ!
Why was that guy just there?!
Did he just--I didn't even see him warp in,
he just appeared!
The fuck was that about?!
No god damn idea.
Alright, anyways, I've got a lot of rare materials
but what the fuck...
That guy needs to learn some god damn manners.
Okay, so I've got a lot of rare materials, hopefully it doesn't
warp me out of my fricken base,
so I don't think I have anything I need for that...
alright
Just gonna start dumping in and I'll coordinate
it later once I know that I'm not gonna DIE...
At least I've got plenty of...
power...
gah-fuck that guy
fuck that guy!
IS THAT YOU MOANING OUT THERE?
HUH!?
Was it you moaning down in the deep depths?
HUH?
Is it because you have no friends 'cause you're an asshole?
I have a funny feeling like that might be the
truth of the matter...
At least I got big water here
big
big water baby
big water
SWEEEEET
all the water I could possibly need!
Thank you very much water filtration devices!
I've got my bio-reactors all--
wh-that's not okay...
Okay, I think that has to do with the weirdness of me deleting
my, uh...
my save game files,
but it does seem to reduce some lag,
so I think I can...
I think I can deal with that!
I think I can deal with a little creep into my...
into my god damn place here, but you know,
that's ok.
Small price to pay, I suppose.
OK, so I'm going to read some lockers now
that I was able to get back to my base and the warper is
being really weird outside of my base, I don't know why,
but I seem to be safe in here.
Uhh, NinjacatCarol2 said:
"You can dock your PRAWN suit
in the cyclops if you make one,"
and I didn't even know that I could do that, uh
it's gonna be a bit of time before I'm able to make
a cyclops, because I gotta go get enamel
for enamelled glass
I gotta go pry the teeth out of
stalkers, so that I can do that.
Uh, then there was Robin Hadx
who said: "you need to build a second
moonpool, so Bumblebutt and Mr. Fister
don't have to take turns keeping the warpers company."
Uh, I'm starting to think there's only one warper,
and it's just following me around like a
DOUCHE
and I don't even know why he is doing that, but
hopefully he's having fun being an asshole out in the
middle of the god damn ocean, but
I think just one moonpool is enough for now
I gotta conserve my resources.
And then Scootermax2 said:
"There's a total of four
precursor bases apparently:
the quarantine enforcement platform, which is the
Big Gun,
the disease research facility,
which is located in the Lost River--"
I imagine if I go just a little bit deeper
and I'm able to upgrade my, um, Mr. Fister
to be able to go down there,
uh, I'll be able to find that one, and maybe
that one uses the orange one
the orange key that I have.
But there's also the precursor power
generator, which is located within the Lava Castle,
which is down in the Active Lava Zone,
and then finally,
there is the
primary containment facility, which will eventually
house the sea-emperor
and is found in the Active Lava Zone, and has
several teleporters, as well as a
room with a deactivated warper
and there are other warpers there, and
other aggressive sea-life will begin protecting you
and I have no idea what that means but,
apparently that's later on and not
implemented in the game just yet.
So hopefully we'll be able to see that but thank you
Scootmax for that information.
NOW, we need to--
fuck we need ta-uh fuck I need to
fill these things hang on one second I need to get more--
get more shit inta these
bad boys...
I think there's no other way around it,
there's one thing that I have to do
above all else to be able to get farther
in this game and I think
number one, primarily, above
anything else that I could do,
I have to make a cyclops.
I just have to do it there's no
way around it there's no way I'm gonna get
farther in the game unless I right now
dedicate myself to getting the
resources necessary to be able to build
that cyclops. And it's not too hard:
plasteel ingot is fine I've got enough
titanium on me right now to be able to
make that plasteel and I have the lithium,
the enameled glass, it's a bit of a
bitch, you just gotta get the teeth from the
stalkers, lubricant's easy, advanced wiring kit, can do that.
But I gotta go back to the other
place to be able to do it,
I've gotta go back to the...
drop ship, and then I gotta go back to Billy, Jef--
Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise, and Marshal
BY THE AURORA, to be able to get
that thing actually built.
SO, this is gonna take a lot of work.
I need to get the materials necessary,
I've got enough that I'm gonna be
able to do it -- in fact right now I'm just gonna
make the titanium necessary TO be able
to do that because... I've got it now,
WHY NOT, I can do it, it's cool
and everything gonna be okay, but then
I gotta go get the enameled glass, and that's gonna take...
I'm pretty sure you need to tame some stalkers to be able to do that.
Even if I DON'T need to tame stalkers,
I'm gonna go tame stalkers,
and see how that goes for me--I do--
honestly have no idea how that's gonna go for me, I'm...
pretty sure it's gonna go very bad for me, but...
We shall see.
So
I'm gonna do that,
I'll be right back when I get to the stalker section of this...
...endeavor...
and...
hopefully I won't get my face bitten off,
I will be able to get some glass,
and some teeth...
and just generally have a good time without being terrified n' dead.
In that order
because
after I'm dead, I-uh-wh... I'm just dead.
Just a few of these for the roooad...
(chomping noises)
Yumyumyumyumyum, in my tumtumtum!
A'right, LET'S ROOOOLL, BABY!
LET'S ROLL.
Hopefully we can get around this warper--
I should name that warper!
I'm gonna call you...
Wallaby the Warper Don't Even Think About Comin' After Me Ya Big 'Ol Bag O' DOUCHE (too long, Mark.)
Wilford? Wilford the Warper?
I could call him Wilford! <3
I'm gonna call him Wilford the Warper.
(Warfstache voice) Oh Wilford the Warper,
how 'bout ya go eat a bag o' di-yucks...
Alright, so the recipe to be able to tame a stopper (I think you mean stalker)
is to have balls of steel,
and then a whole lotta peeper (heh...)
and then you just kinda like,
when it's comin' after you, you go:
"Wh-uh! EE-EAT-I-NOTME!
EAT THIS ONE! EAT IT!
OH MY GOD IDON'TWANNADIEEATTHIS KILL IT INSTEAD OF MEEE!!" (Sounds about right)
And then hope for the best...
(muttering) I think that's it anyway, I'm not 100% sure about it...
But MAYBE,
Maybe that's exactly what you're supposed to be doing
and then, uh...
you DON'T die, and it becomes your friend
so long as you feed it.
'Cuz that's how friendship works,
you just keep feeding people
until they like ya,
they don't like ya anymore and they don't wanna be your friend, so...
Life lessons from Markiplier:
keep your friends fed.
And then keep 'em at an arm's d-th-lengthhh... distance, whatever.
Alright so step number one to imminent friendship:
1.) Gather peepers.
Gather all the peepers that you can possibly gather,
doesn't matter if they're alive...
I'll call this "Fishing with Bumblebutt."
Where'd you go?
WHERE THE FU--you makin' a fool o' me?
FINE, I'll find other peepers that wanna play with me.
(dumb voice) Hu-thpbth, thorry!
(stalker screech) OW, fuc--God dammit,
you were supposed to hit the peeper, not me!
Fuck you. -_-
A'right, c'mere peepers!
Whole lotta ya, huh?
Ohh, there's a lotta peepers.
I just know that stalkers like peepers ehh-specifically.
I dunno why,
but they like 'em.
Hey, you wanna peeper? (Sancho shriek)
Hey, you wanna peeper? Eugh...
I have no idea how this is gonna go...
whOa boy...
do you just, like...
D--
I dunno.
Do you just, like... say hi to 'em?
Do you release it at 'em?
Where'd you go?
Did THEY fuckin' dissappear?
(high-pitched dog-whistle Mark) The fuck did they go--
Ohh, they're over there.
O-kay.
Alright, uh...
hey, you wanna peeper?
I got a peeper for ya!
Nice fresh peepee! (Mark...)
I'll trade you for that--
(hungry stalker snarl)
WHOA
You wanna peeper?
Wh-u-oh-AHHH...!
Ho... ho fuck--AGH
Fuckin'...
You wanna peeper?
Huh? (SNARL)
Fuck
FUCK
Peep--
Get... peeper... heh?
(Jealous stalkers) Fuckin' STOP...
You want a peeper just TAKE IT, God damn it!
I'll take this!
Ugh... man, this is scary
okay
alright
HEEEEY, FRIEND, thanks for bringin' me shit!
D'you want this peeper?
I'll take that, oogh.
Okay, you want a peeper?
Ooh-- (dolphin-like squeak)
Uwhahh?
(Growl)
Whuuugh...
Heh!
Hugh!
Eat it!
Woah shit, oh my God...
I think it's my friend!
(stalker shrieks, Mark is uncertain) Oh my God, I think it's my friend...?
(dolphin-y noises)
OOOH, I think it's my friend! :D
I'm not 100% sure about this
because I'm not very sure about anything,
but I think it's my friend?
You want a peeper?
*boink!*
Blublblbleleh...
Eat it!
Yeh--yeah, yeah, eat it, eat it, eat it...
Nooo...
He lost interest! God damn it!
Karen: Emergency--
Mark: Oh, fuck off.
Karen: --ten seconds of oxygen remaining.
Mark: I KNOW, dammit...
HUUUHduhblup...
(wait for it...)
BLEHH!
Man, life was a lot harder when I had to worry about oxygen.
Okay so now that I tamed it, what do I do?
Do get fuckin'... teeth from it?
Gimme your goddaooauugh...
It's a friend...
Okay, I'll scan you I guess,
you're just letting me scan ya...
Yeesh, these things are hard to scan!
Boop!
O-okay I got...
friends with a fuckin' stalker, I g--I guess?
Hey you want one? Hey you want one buddy?
I'm gonna watch...
Oh, man, you gotta farm over here.
I'll just take those, steal your shit.
You want one? Huehh...
WHOAAA
Okay...
Did it drop a tooth?
I didn't see a tooth.
(curious stalker shriek)
No?
One--(ROAR) O-kay.
Fuck, what happened to all my peepers?
Wh--I HAD A WHOLE BUNCHA PEEPERS!
I couldn't have thrown all my peepers at it, I had a bunch!
Oh FACK.
I go--I guess they're my friends now?
I-I think?
But they didn't give me what I wanted!
That's not how friendship works!
I give you something, you give me what I want!
That's how it's SUPPOSED to be anyway, I-I think...
You come back here let me feed you a stalker,
IT'S LIKE YOU'RE AFRAID OF DEATH, come on!
Whaya doin'??
Stop bein' such a doooouche...
(Swedish?) I've got nice juicy peeper for you~
(Roaring stalker)
Oop oop ooh what the fuck--
WHOA, fuckin'... God dammit, that thing...
AHHH fucking God damn it, get the fuck off my arm!
Stop
Stop (x2)
Stop (x3)
Stop (x4)
Stop (x5)
Stop (x6)
Stop (x7), I've got other problems to deal with, GODDAMMIT, this is so hard.
UUUUGH WHY'S GOT A GOD--GIB-BE A GODDAMN NIGHTMARE?
How 'bout you guys you wanna...
you wanna bite my ass?
Bite my ass.
Bite my ass. (x2)
Bite my ass. (x3)
Bite it! BITE MY ASS! (Good God, Mark.)
Don-- I didn't think I'd have to shout that in the middle of the goddamn ocean.
~BITE MY ASS!~
Alright, so that didn't quite work out,
but then again I always knew that was gonna be trouble,
getting the teeth from stalkers has always been my Achilles' Heel.
I don't know what I'm doing wrong,
I'll go look it up just in case it changed,
but I got them to bite my Seamoth,
I got them to...
be my friend, but then again it just didn't seem to be working out,
I will look into this in the future and hopefully,
HOPEFULLY,
I will have an answer for you very soon but just right now,
I just...
I got a lot of peepers in my pants and I don't have a lot of answers
but by the next episode I will have all the materials b-ready and able to build the Cyclops.
Because it shouldn't be too hard,
so long as I'm able to get what I need to get.
So I'm gonna do exactly that, so...
thank you everybody so much for watching,
let me know how I'm doing down in the comments below,
thank you one and all for joining me one this epic adventure and cheering me on!
I will build the Seamahllugh (smooth.)
I will build a Cyclops in the very next episode
and hopefully get you guys to more progress down in the deep Active Lava Zone.
So thanks again everybody so much for watching,
and as always, I will see you in the next video.
BUHBYE~! (Bye Mark!)
(Outro music)